voilà un sondage qui fait beaucoup
parler depuis ce week-end un sondage
publié par le journal du dimanche dont
les différentes propositions de réponses
ont beaucoup choqué les lecteurs un
sondage choc
y at il trop de noirs trop de musulmans
pro de maghrébins une étude réalisée par
l'ifop pour sos racisme et l'uejf il
fait beaucoup de bruit et le début de
l'article le jdd prévient les questions
sont parfois dérangeante mais l'objectif
est clair et utile mesurer les préjugés
et la prééminence du racisme dans la
société est en effet pour être
dérangeante elles le sont on retrouve
par exemple ce type de proposition de
très stigmatisante et des résultats qui
peut paraître très inquiétant sur les
réseaux sociaux ce sondage est très mal
passée
nombreux sont ceux qui se sont exprimés
en défaveur d'un tel sondage surtout sur
la forme
alors le sondage du jdd est il raciste
gc chez vous il est 19h47 merci yassine
belattar d'être là merci aux prêts
normaux
merci d'être là l'humoriste yacine
faudra aller voir son spectacle très
très très très drôle yacine des cons
pour aller voir des spectacles
il faut aller le voir et guillaume bigot
politologue merci d'être là guillaume
alors nancy lorraine ont vite et si vous
avez tous une petite pancarte we yacine
pourquoi les il est raciste son âge il
est déjà raciste surtout que c'est
interdit en france de faire des
statistiques ethniques
et puis surtout ce qui est très gênant
c'est que ça met dans une impasse sos
racisme et l'uejf parce que je pense pas
qu'ils étaient conscients du contenu à
la fin et surtout je pense quitte à
aller au bout du sondage autant écrire
les juifs avec des doigts crochus les
arabes avec des tapis volant c'est juste
qu'elle s'est pas lancé nauséabond c'est
dégueulasse et puis surtout ça annonce
quelque chose que ici on essaye de
lutter contre cela mais ça annonce la
prochaine élection présidentielle dans
quel contexte ça va se passer quoi alors
gilles verdez vous dit non non je suis
pas du tout d'accord
le sondage n'est pas raciste et je
trouve qu'il agit sur moi en tout cas
comme un électrochoc
une prise de conscience les réponses
sont durs très durs insoutenable mais
c'est pas le sondage qui est
problématique c'est justement l'état des
réponses et je suis pas d'accord et
cassine
c'est maintenant qu'il faut lutter parce
que rien n'est joué donc il faut se
battre pour les idées et si les français
pensent ça il faut les convaincre du
contraire
et je vais vous dire franchement moi je
suis pas très surpris des réponses
moines attendais pas mais il est mal
présentés c'est ça le problème alors
vous trouvez que les dates et les gens
n'ont pas compris ils ont cru
effectivement que c'est un sondage
d'ultra racistes alors que c'est un
sondage qui est mal présentés
qu'effectivement étant demandée par sos
racisme et l'union
quinze villes de france il est forcément
pas raciste mais il est maladroit
stéphane da [ __ ] is et supra raciste
parce que c'est encore une fois divisent
et il a raison on n'a pas besoin de ça
on sait ce que ça va donner au deuxième
tour c'est tout le monde contre le pen
aujourd'hui sont tous en train de se
battre pour être la deuxième place face
à elle et je comprends pas que sos
racisme europe 1 soit à l'origine de ça
je préfère que la soirée qu'ils vont le
faire demain soir mais dominique un
super travail je pense qu'il était pas
vraiment au courant de ce sondage
oui mais alors ils sont vraiment contre
les énoncer des questions il faut qu'ils
prennent tout de suite position disons
on n'est pas d'accord avec ce qui s'est
dit mais non c'est les préjugés
nicolas pernikoff les musulmans elle est
là grébert qui a les étrangers
extrêmement étonné de ta réponse
c'est vrai tu mène une bataille en
permanence sur certaines choses c'est un
électrochoc extraordinaire vous dire que
maintenant il va y avoir une bataille à
mener
il va falloir convaincre des gens il va
falloir faire comprendre aux gens qu'on
peut tous vivre ensemble
là clairement sa mémoire choquer ni
baisser ses coûts si sur des sujets tels
cas qui assigne fin on a des désaccords
mais si tu veut conditionner les gens à
croire que ce qui est différent et
forcément dangereuses que les gens
pensent non c'est parce que maintenant
on sait qu'une partie des gens pensent
déjà sont activés voilà ce qui pousse
les gens ne regardent pas tpm partie des
gens mais la réalité c'est que déjà
positionné l'idée que selon sa
différence on peut être dangereux c'est
quoi la soirée demain je veux dire quoi
qu'il faut se taire non mais c'est pas
se taire face tu vois pas de terres face
à quelque chose qui est normal qu'ils
aient déjà le fait de reconnaître que
nous sommes français déjà appelé les
gens les musulmans les maghrébins et
noir cette audition est ce que les gens
qui ont été qui ont été questionnés
c'est script en son nom mais moi j'ai
une grille mais c'est fragile radine el
hammam annonce qu'il faut que tu fasses
c'est ce que tu fais depuis très
longtemps il faut combattre l'ignorance
et il faut expliquer aux gens ce que je
pense ce tronc de 100 et moi on me
d'avancé face à des accords que j'ai
avec l'invitant phase de figure toi je
pense que vraiment les gens sont
persuadés que ces gens là font peur et
j'ai encore on fait quand on fait rire
contre le racisme c'est qu'ils les gens
c'est une très bonne question
les gens confondent d'interrogent déjà
sur le résultat du
du sondage moi je préfère rire contre le
racisme que de provoquer des
électrochocs ne crois pas qu'on sent
juste pour aller au bout de 60 ans il ya
des gens qui ont peur bien sûr se
rhabille maison plus en plus des éclats
mais plus peur c'est une équipe en main
mais déjà n'y pensons plus sur scène il
ya certaines personnes en trop dans ce
pays a déjà accompli
on ne sait pas de légende et l'adage le
dit excusez moi je crois qu'il ya un
petit souci en fait de compréhension en
fait il faut vraiment je pense que vous
entendez pas je comprends évidemment ce
que tu es en train de dire c'est que
déjà on a un petit problème en france
n'a pas droit évidemment de faire des
statistiques ethniques
donc quand on voit les questions qui
sont posées moi ça me pose vraiment
problème parce que déjà les questions
posées mettre les gens en fait donc dans
leurs limites
exactement il est en fait je comprends
ce que tu veux dire mais c'est pas avec
ce questionnaire là qu'on va faire
réagir les gens qu'on va les éduquer et
qu'on va les faire bouger sur les
discriminations moi c'est ça qui me pose
problème parce qu'on est là pour éduquer
les gens évidemment est qu'à ses tous
les stéréotypes mais pas avec ce
questionnaire là on va aller on va les
pousser et finalement dans leurs
retranchements et le raciste qui va
répondre à cette question là il n'aura
aucun recul sur le racisme en fait c'est
ça qui me pose problème moi le jeu point
positif c'est que il ya un comparatif en
mais tout est en baisse tout est en
baisse c'est le seul point positif c'est
partiel à partir et guillaume bigot g
skill et rassis ce sont là et ce qu'ils
doivent ou de choquer ou non ça n'a pas
de sens de dire qu'il y aura aussi ça
voudrait dire que lieu jf au sos racisme
se laissera assisterait beaucoup de
choses à dire sur le soap haut mais
franchement on peut les accuser de tous
et pâle et raciste évidemment c'est
absurde pour moi c'est bon je pense que
la question je sais pas qui a posé la
question la question a vraiment pas de
sens en revanche c'est surtout le
sondage qui n'a pas le sens pourquoi
quand vous faites un sondage déjà les
sondages on sait qu'on peut leur faire
dire des tas de trucs mais
méthodologiquement vous demandez à
quelqu'un
s'ils mangent de la viande plutôt que du
poisson s'ils votent à droite toki à
gauche pour demander si les racistes lui
ou s'il est pas raciste
là c'est quoi sera ce sondage est une
énorme arnaque vous demander aux gens
s'ils pensent que les autres sont
racistes
mais évidemment les racistes c'est
toujours les autres c'est jamais soi
même c'est complètement délirant et
c'est évidemment une utilisation très
intéressante pourquoi ce débat ce soir
parce que moi pour moi il ya une mineure
été privilégiée en france ils ont
globalement fermer des usines en france
ils ont fait baisser les salaires ils
ont fait venir ici des gens qu'il se
paye parce que la plupart du temps les
migrants ne sont pas déclarés n'accepte
pas sur les dégâts ce qu'on fabrique
mais bien sûr c'est le coeur du sujet
non non le business et les lakers locaux
qui le business est privilégiée à faire
croire qu'il ya du racisme d'une part et
d'autre part à exciter les différences
et les haines entre les gens ce sondage
sert à ça le jdd et la pravda de macron
monsieur belattar était le bouffon du
roi il a servi macron ça va dans le bon
sens c'était de bosser pour les nommer
guillaume bigot c'est pas le débat
deuxième si c'est des journées des
macros le sec sur ces news long tunnel
où vous dites que de la merde moi ici je
dois vous répondent
1 2 vous porter très bien votre nom je
vous dire le troisième essai de mails
faveur niveau si vous insultez parce que
visiblement la regarde et bien d'autres
ne la regardez ce que cette volée dans
le brouillard est là pour faire
interdire regarder les français pour
faire mes gardes et débrouillardise et
sur les noms savoyard dernier vient
répondre mais regardez à la alors ça
fait pas la mer 0 dit que mon ombre je
pas bien mon nom mais regardez il faut
dire la vérité aux places au wave ou là
moi je viens vous faire insulter
alors oui c'est vrai que c'est le beauf
est déjà sous le bouffon de personnes
et deuxièmement me traiter de bata
objectivement je vous ai menace était de
batteur mais il dit que je porte et bien
fini et je peux finir dit que c'était
aussi malin je peux feu de dire que
mieux je me trouve ne rime avec bâtard
je vais très moyen c'est quoi sinon s'il
vous plaît non mais c'est quoi
l'hôpital heures j'aurai donc celles au
tour vous écoute sur un an mais a déjà
faut pas me tutoyez je suis pas votre
chauffeur et escarpé tutoyer ans un des
diamants je crois que vous aviez vous
mais vous les perdez tout c'est un minet
yacine non mais objectivement vous êtes
là vous faites partie je vous écoute
vous êtes présidentiable vous êtes là
depuis tout à l'heure
là les français vous venez de leur
donner un exemple que seule cette
émission peut souligner c'est que les
racailles sont pas du côté où l'on pense
vous insultez vous provoquez vous êtes
là vous n'êtes même pas capable de vous
remettre en question aujourd'hui quand
vous commencez votre intitulé attendait
quand vous commencez votre attitude et
par le fait de faire croire oui je
connais le président de la république ça
vous pose un problème
ce que ça vous pose un problème
parce que c'est un problème bruit
problème c'est parce que attendez je
vais au bout de ma phrase savoureuse et
une diction jour arabes et les noirs de
ce pays qui sont français qui porte la
fierté d'être français tous les jours
tant tous tout en ayant une culture
annexes qui leur permet de croire en un
dieu ou non une culture vous pose
problème la réponse est oui
la caravane garder ce qu'on fait tous
les jours sur ses news allez on refait
le monde à leur place et ensuite pour
alain donné là je voudrais pas ce que
vous voudrez bien avant de circuler ou
poser une question à vous poser des
questions et vous révélez votre minimes
les mais pourquoi monsieur voit son pari
osé mais qui paraît ce que vous êtes en
terrain conquis là vous allez faire la
parole ici guillaume vraiment de quoi
vous parlez maintenant mais c'est vous
ces raisons d juste moi j'aimerais
comprendre pas laisser la parole à des
gens qui viennent sur ce plateau
quand c'est pas genre messia ces bigots
qui passent leur vie à venir sur un
plateau parce que c'est des anneaux est
la première fois qu une dernière oui
c'est vous allez j'ose truc qui je n'ose
y verra mais c'est bon vous êtes loin de
vous donner l'autorité vous réclamez et
les mondes rien d'hôpital j'essaye de
parler vous êtes l'homme décide de tout
ça vous je vais pas vous faire quoi que
ce soit je lui dis en face de moi que
personne vous connais vous êtes
personnes et qu'aujourd'hui pour
utiliser un discours qui fait parler
mais beaucoup de gens en mission à pas
comment j'ai des points de désaccord
avec plein de chroniqueurs que les
choses soient bien claires mais ça nous
empêche pas d'avoir un but commun c'est
que le fait que les gens puissent vivre
ensemble dans un pays qui porte soit 165
millions de personnes vous vous
réveillez le matin avec des lubies en
disant faut casser du [ __ ] faut
casser du [ __ ] où on va leur envoyer
des centaines joue très vite dans les
rues nos médias j'ai dit ça en plus aux
seuls fia une jeune eddy minidou redire
ici laver les homicides et les janvier
moi je met à la page en mai et je
revienne sur ce plateau valait pas mieux
que lui pour dire que les missions qui
les reçoit avoir déjà c'est pas une
émission qui est bien et deuxièmement
grosse que j'ai mené des missions de la
vérité nous on vit sur une lubie qui est
celle de dire un moment que ce sondage à
vous avez commencé votre intitulé par
dire faire un raccourci entre le sondage
et les migrants ce que vous voyez nadège
chez moi où la femme de
gilles verdez ou cyril hanouna comme de
potentiels gens forcément issus de
l'immigration n'est pas comme français
parce que le débat commence là le débat
tout ça bien sûr je vais me répondre je
suis d'abord la première chose pour
débattre c'est s'écouter je vous ai
écoutés écoutez moi ce que je vous ai
dit c'est qu'à part un rapport entre les
migrants et ce sondage il ya un rapport
entre une politique économique qui a
diminué les salaires qui a écrasé les
salaires qui a fait l'europe qui a fait
des délocalisations et pour se justifier
qui a besoin d'accuser les français
d'être racistes et ce sondage est
commandée par le jdd le jdd de notoriété
publique et proche du président la
république
je ne vous reproche pas d'avoir été
proche de prévost la république et vous
avez vous songé
oui j'ai l'ambition du renard et ça veut
dire quoi ça ça veut dire quoi vivre
parce que c'est mais c'est à dire quoi
vous appelle pas belattar de nulle part
c'est mon abonnement très bien je vous
réponds que c'est une figure assez
classique dans l'histoire de france
parce que les rois de france avec des
bouffons avec des clochettes donc c'est
comme ça ils vont vous voyez je peux
terminer ça que vous je me taire les
dérangerait de débattre je n'ai jamais
pensé donc déjà baissé prompt à son
charisme et vous dit à marie c'est une
manière vaisselle vous ne m'avez jamais
belgique je voulais casser enigmz est
synchronisé vous allez mais je voulais
traiter ce que je vous dis fini s'est
jamais laissé géraldine ya d'autres
choses encore je réponds simplement que
c'est le bouffon du roi dans la
tradition des rois de france c'est
quelqu'un on a compris que ces puits qui
faisait rire le voit mais moi je vais
soit en fait la base elle fait des
blagues je pense que ce genre de guide
genre de son dard est fait pour le
pouvoir
je ne suis personne parce que je voulais
combien la dette excusez moi je vous ai
menti veut dire qu'il ya des jeunes qui
nous regardent des jeunes qui sont
discriminés des jeunes qui sont en
souffrance je ne pourrais pas apaisé le
débat est ce que vous pourriez pas vous
et de vous écouter un petit peu je suis
désolé mais je crois que la menace est
très serré mais la belle vous êtes sûrs
du type non nadège papillon se fait
agresser comme tu veux la grèce devrait
battre c'est comme sédatif d'appeler
quelqu'un bouffe ouais c'est vrai
écouter j'avais le battre d'un sondage
on parlait du fond du sondage et
monsieur mais non mais vous de parler il
parlait sur la corde et non et vous
n'êtes pas seuls a commencé par dire
gérer pour la vie d'un fou du roi qui
s'appelle comment vous arrivez ici non
plus n'avait qu'un arrogant incroyable
vous êtes sur le plateau même la rime
avec bâtard bouffon monsieur saute on
nous a dit y était il m'a dit mais on
dira je porte mes brouillons mais avant
oui vous invectivé les gens d'une
manière extrêmement violente
peut-être que vous n'avez pas d'idées et
que vous voulez masquer votre vacuité
mais très franchement vous pouvez pas
insulter les gens comme ça mais ce
serait mieux si l'unité de mesure de la
vacuité effectivement s'il vous plaît
pas de coke et de punch line dance e
d'abyssales si je puis me permettre
moi je suis plutôt d'accord avec à sindh
en revenant quand même à ce sondage
exemple je trouve que c'est un sondage
plutôt stérile plutôt inutile pourquoi
parce qu'en fait qu'ils qui votent en
fait gastines c'est à dire qu'il ya un
moment donné monsieur qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
est-ce que parmi les musulmans disent
qu'ils sont contre les noirs après tout
lire le sondage représentatif de la
possède on sait pas qui va voter mais
voilà on n'a pas de ces maisons
catholiques intégristes c'est pas
forcément sans la génération identitaire
qui votent
est ce que pendant les asiatiques sont
gênés par les noirs est-ce que les
protestants sont gênés par les juifs
est ce que les catholiques sont gênés
par les musulmans et les musulmans eux
mêmes sont gênés par les événements les
étrangers en général
donc on paye pour moi c'est un usage
totalement stérile complètement inutile
qui ne sert à rien il faut lutter contre
les discriminations aulas joue
par exemple al embauche ça c'est utile
mais ça sert à rien ça nous fait le coup
nous dit vivre ça nous fait que nous
exclure ça n'apporte aucune solution et
franchement c'est entendu l'année par ce
sondage nicolas tout à l'heure tu disais
que ça ferait avancer les choses ce
genre de sondages que tu penses vraiment
plus ce genre de d'études ça fait
avancer les choses contre le racisme
avec des questions absurdes qui sont
posées il ya plein de questions sur les
clichés aussi sur les préjugés ce que
vous pensez que les juifs au plus
d'argent que les autres en fait le
racisme c'est tellement nul c'est
tellement absurde que ça ne sert à rien
de l'analyse et de le décortiquer et
même le jdd le reconnaît au début il dit
ils disent les questions sont parfois
dérangeantes oui effectivement c'est
très dérangeant c'est gênant et ça ne
sert à rien merci ce qui est et ce qui
est impressionnant c'est le climat dans
lequel on se trouve
et vraiment je n'ai pas à répondre à ce
qui se disait tout à l'heure parce que
je suis affecté par l'idée de se dire
qu'aujourd'hui les gens racisées arabes
noirs ou autres le asia team ico part
rarement par exemple de la communauté
asiatique ce qui souffrent elles
quasiment d'un racisme encore plus
poussée qui est celui de l'anonymat
complet c'est à dire on dit les chinois
pour tous les asiatiques et voilà mais
l'histoire de l'immigration en france
pour parler à tous les chroniqueurs
elle se fait sur quelque chose qui est
en mouvement et et on peut pas figer une
société comme le font d'ailleurs bigot
et d'autres c'est à dire de dire avant
c'était mieux ou mais aujourd'hui la
réalité c'est que nos enfants pour
parler de ta leur ont parlé moi j'ai
deux adolescents que chez moi par
l'occurrence la leçon l'âge avancé t
pierre pinon mais il y avait surtout la
menace des pirates par exemple ou
charlie et donc tu es tombé parler de ce
qu'on vous parlait tout à l'heure
nos enfants sont des citoyens du monde
qui quand ils regardent ces sondages la
disent de quoi on parle
c'est à dire vraiment et quand je vois
par exemple un sondage qui m'a plus
intéressés sur celui de la laïcité dans
les lycées où les jeunes quelle que soit
leur couleur la rejette
parce qu'en fait tout simplement ils
voient pas les gens à travers un prisme
y les arabes et les noirs ses copains de
classe et je vous parle de ça une gamine
d'argenteuil a quand même été assassinés
suite à un harcèlement
les problèmes sont transcommunautaire
transgénérationnel mais surtout ce qui
m'inquiète c'est l'idée même que
aujourd'hui par exemple moi j'aime pas
charlie hebdo
je rejoins ce qui a été dit c'est moi si
je vois un anglais je vais me faire un
malin plaisir de lui dire que nous on a
le droit de le faire
je trouve pas ça drôle je trouve ça un
peu grossier mais l'idée même qu'un
anglais puisse me dire que je dois
changer pour lui plaire ça je suis pas
d'accord mais oui singing woods et dire
qu'il faudrait dire non mais c'est pas
mal là on revient sur le fond revient
sur la scène
j'étais là c'est mieux quand vous êtes
comme ça voilà ledger et pas de vous je
vais lui les bars donc alors et droite
très dure et longue vie à toi tais toi
en fait si vous voulez le racisme c'est
c'est la haine pure et c'est exactement
comme l'amour on peut dire de dieu de la
haine ce qu'on peut dire de l'amour
certes l'amour c'est bien ça n'existe
pas il ya des preuves d'amour la haine
c'est pareil là elle en général et
surtout interrogé je répète les gens sur
ce qu'ils pensent de la haine du voisin
c'est là à mon avis aucun sens donc il
faut des preuves de haine
où sont ses preuves de l combien de de
jean racisées comme vous dites j'ai une
passe ter sont tués en france parce
qu'ils sont racisées ça existe c'est
terminé on a terminé les chiffres il ya
deux sont plus de 260 personnes qui sont
en revanche été qui ont été tués par les
analystes regardez régionaux à 62%
mais c'est comment on peut sortir une
phrase comme une trace tenir là dessus à
dire les ne meurt pas et 262 personnes
ont été tuées par l'islamisme et bien
cet homme est basse reste un boire ils
arrêtent un bel âge qui tuent les gens
voilà des gens qui en jute le vif au nom
d'une religion les gens c'est bien car
nous ayons à une religion et jean mais
c'est un jeu de par une idéologie sur
une course qui donnera six coups
clochette